daily wire is a
fom and they like to have kind of a
stable of people in their team but who
are completely under their thumb uh
remember the Crowder business which
happened not that long ago and I thought
it was so odd because what what appear
to be a private negotiation suddenly
erupts into public well why well
apparently what Crowder was was kind of
um balking against was the idea of quote
being owned by the daily wire right and
and I think this is what's going on here
is that Candace is a very independent
Spirit she's actually got a pretty good
ego she wants to be her own person and
yet somehow she's corraled into the
daily wire stable and they expect her to
quote behave and she doesn't really
think she needs to she's Candice she
doesn't need to she doesn't need to